I am on the same page as you I believe I
I think there's something to be said for
all of the different Pockets blocks
dogmas uh all the information out there
whether it's religion or science
um and I feel like my opinion is I feel
like things that are spiritual are just
things that's that science hasn't proven
yet what does religion or spirituality
get right then religion gets a couple
things very very right a couple of them
that science gets wrong and a couple
that science gets right spiritual
Traditions especially the Eastern
mystical ones
but but also a Christian mystical
um you know it's like Benedictine monks
kind of thing
um get right that space and time and the
physical what we call the physical world
is not the fundamental reality I think
they're right about that there is
something beyond space and time and
until recently science got that wrong
science assume that space-time was
fundamental Einstein thought space time
was fundamental for example uh and of
course I admire Einstein but you know as
a scientist you have to to admire them
but then move forward and now physics
has moved forward best physicists are
now saying space time is not fundamental
they say space time is doomed so their
science is converging with spirituality
and saying that space-time is not
fundamental so so that's something that
that
um spirituality has gotten correct I
would say another thing that
spirituality has gotten correct is that
they say that reality
whatever it is beyond space-time they
will use the word God and so forth or or
Brahman or or
whatever it might be they'll say that
that transcends any description we can
give it's beyond any language so that
the language that we use should not be
taken as
the thing is just a pointer so the the
good is say the finger pointing to the
Moon is not the Moon
but and and and so I think that they get
that right and if scientists who say we
We've Got a Theory of Everything
and and they believe that then they've
got it wrong I think most scientists who
say we have a theory of everything it's
with a wink and a nod they they know
that it's not the final Theory of
Everything But there are some who who
think that they are looking for the
final theory of everything and and there
I think they're wrong and I think
they're wrong because of girdle's
incompleteness theorem
or this guy named Kurt girdle approved
around 1930 that uh basically anything
that you can write down precisely
um and is powerful enough to for example
be able to do arithmetic with it then
there will he showed that there will
always be things that are true that
cannot be stated in that language that
they can't can't be proven that I'll put
it can't be proven in your theoretical
language so the notion of Truth
transcends the notion of proof and
therefore the notion of scientific
theory and that means that there's an
unbounded intelligence as far as the way
I think of it there's this unbounded set
of truths and therefore there's
unbounded intelligence Beyond any
description that we could give in
language or scientific theories and so
the spiritual Traditions have said that
for a long time without you they said
our language would never do anything but
point to the reality now science has
caught up with that I think most
scientists really understand this so you
can see that there is this convergence
but then the question is what is beyond
space-time what what how should we talk
about that intelligence even though we
know that ultimately our descriptions
aren't hit
nevertheless
descriptions aren't completely
irrelevant so that's the interesting
tension
[Music]
um I'm fascinated by the idea that
space-time is doomed I'm maybe we back
up and
back up and like try and unpack like
this reality first like I'm curious
about this what is the reality Earth
this experience at this point in time
and then I want to understand like what
is our our human reality what is this
experience from a physical body so maybe
start with this reality that we were in
let's try to answer that question we off
to say you know what framework that I'm
using for and I'll give you an answer
from a different framework so if I and
I'm saying these Frameworks are correct
I'm just saying these are the Frameworks
that I use to think about this kind of
thing so one is the evolutionary
framework right so if I just put on a
hard-nosed evolutionary biology kind of
point of view what most people think
that entails is that there is a real
physical world there are real physical
organisms they evolve and they reproduce
and when your body dies that's it that's
that's the standard view of most of my
colleagues my own work with my my um
collaborators caitan prakash um seeing
Robert prentner
several Brian Marion and Justin Mark a
bunch of us have been working on this
we've realized that when you look at the
mathematics of evolutionary theory
it entails that our perceptions are not
telling us the truth the probability
that we've been shaped to see reality as
it is is zero and it's a it's a clean
theorem of that of that theory and that
means that even though Darwin when he
came up with a theory was thinking about
a real physical world with real physical
objects and animals and so forth
in fact this is more like a virtual
reality what what evolution gave us from
this point of view is not a window on
the truth it gave us a headset a VR
headset to play the game of life and you
know if you to play a game in VR if you
had to toggle voltages in a computer to
play the game good luck you would lose
against someone who had a nice little
headset that knew showed you how to like
drive a steering wheel to you know to
drive a car or something like that turn
the steering wheel to drive a car so if
if from an evolutionary point of view we
were shaped with senses that guide
adaptive Behavior Keep Us Alive long
enough to reproduce period
they don't show us the truth so
Evolution also agrees that space-time is
not fundamental it's just a data
structure is just a headset
so so that's one perspective on things
then it agrees with what the physicists
are saying physicists now are saying
space time isn't fundamental
by the way Evolution doesn't tell us
what is
right it only tells us that we're seeing
through a VR headset but evolutionary
theory does not have the power to give
us a hint about what's beyond the
headset right it's really interesting
now the physicists they've they have
used the mathematics of quantum field
Theory
uh uh and general relativity together
to discover that space-time is not
fundamental but there they have tools
that allow them to go beyond space-time
and they're doing it so in the last 10
years they so this is fairly recent they
have discovered structures called the
amplitohedron
and cosmological polytope and and the
deepest structures is something called a
decorative permutation so
yeah these are like they're just if
you've seen the movie 2001 the Space
Odyssey but there's the the
scene where there's just the monolith
that's sitting there and all the monkeys
are pounding on it and screaming and you
know they know it's significant but they
don't know what the significance is
right and and so that's where we are
right now we have these these static
monoliths Beyond space-time there's the
geometric structures like the
amplitudehedron and the decorated
they're just sitting there and and my
feeling is that it's amazing we've
discovered the the physicists have
discovered these monoliths but there's
no notion of Dynamics they're just
geometric objects or these mathematical
structures like the decorated
permutations so so that's as far as the
physicists have gotten Beyond space-time
you know are they on other planets moons
are they others are they truly speaking
of structures are they are they uh
frequency structures in space-time this
is hard to do but you have to think
entirely outside of space-time so the
think of space-time as just your headset
and on the other side of the headset are
these structures okay so it's you you
think well okay space time well that
goes out billions and billions of light
years there's trillions of yep that's
just all of that is just your headset
you have to think all the way beyond
that and there are these structures so
kind of like what's beyond infinity
exactly right exactly right where the
infinity is just in your head when I was
a kid was I was looking up and going
what's at the end of this it's Infinity
it doesn't what's out there you just
answered it hats off to the physicist
many many who have contributed to this
but the amplitudehedron was um Nema
arkani Hamed and his collaborators and
uh Juan Maldives and Nema have been have
worked on the cosmological polytope and
others so I'm just mentioning a few
there's many many brilliant people many
of them are at the institute for
advanced study at Princeton um where a
lot of this work has been done and the
the you know the answer to human was
only published in 2013. that's less than
10 years ago so so this is fairly new
and and so that's no surprise that not
too many people know that there are
these structures Beyond space-time and
and many brilliant people have exactly
your question which is how do you put
these structures inside Space time where
where are they and and that's a good
question because it really
points out to know they're entirely
Beyond space-time you have to imagine
that all of space-time as big as it
might seem
is nothing but a little headset
and on the other side of the headset is
in a much more complicated realm
um and but all we know about the realm
from physics is there are these
structures like the monoliths in 2001
and so and no notion of Dynamics now
what I'm working on is the third answer
to your question about you know what's
the reality I'm proposing it's
consciousness
and my my colleague uh colleagues Manish
Singh and caitan prakash and others are
working with me on this Robert prentner
where we're working on a mathematical
model of consciousness
craw Consciousness so it's Consciousness
not as like
an emergent feature of brain activity or
an emergent feature of some artificial
intelligence circuitry or software it's
on it's fundamental like the spiritual
Traditions have said Consciousness is a
fundamental reality and it turns out
with mathematics you can make that
precise and what I'm working on right
now is saying okay a dynamics of
consciousness
outside of space-time is in fact the
Dynamics that gives rise to the
structures that the physicists are
finding like the decorated permutations
and we have a paper that we're about to
submit in in less than two weeks for
publication which we actually show that
mapping from dynamics of conscious
agents into decorative permutations so
we actually can do a mathematical model
that says again this is science and so
of course we're probably wrong but but
but but at least it's precise here's a
mathematical model of dynamics of
Consciousness and this Dynamics gives us
the decorated permutations which you
guys have found Beyond space-time so
this might be the Dynamics behind your
monoliths and the Dynamics of
Consciousness so that's sort of fun
that's super exciting I mean you must be
like I mean publishing is so it takes so
long and there's so much vetting out and
you guys like to break each other's
theories down and that's the sort of
your it's like a quite an aggressive
process to get to publishing so congrats
for sure on that I'll be excited to hear
uh here and see what that um what comes
from that
[Music]